-Performing
"in the wake of your leave"
from their new album,
"angel in realtime"
give it up for Gang of Youths!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ So as you canyoneered
from our world upwards ♪
♪ And the angels
took their place ♪
♪ I was a loser
at your funeral ♪
♪ With no emotion conveyed ♪
♪ It was drawn out in vain ♪
♪ And the idiot I am
just figured ♪
♪ In the wake of your leave ♪
♪ That I'd never hear
from you again ♪
♪ And that I'd sing ♪
♪ With all this feeling ♪
♪ That your spirit
would afford me ♪
♪ My hand on heart ♪
♪ It's not a thing
that I've been dreaming of ♪
♪ And it throws me
with my blessing ♪
♪ And leaves me in a rut ♪
♪ But it comes and goes ♪
♪ And shows me all I'm missing ♪
♪ And it comes and goes ♪
Alright.
♪♪
♪ I was there at the backstage,
trying ♪
♪ But the words,
they never came ♪
♪ I was available
for a statement ♪
♪ But I just hung my head
in shame ♪
♪ It felt nothing to me ♪
♪ All the ceremony I'd wasted ♪
♪ And then I'd thank them
and leave ♪
♪ And say, "God bless you all,
goodnight" ♪
♪ And then I'd think ♪
♪ The grave was turning ♪
♪ And that nothing
would absolve me ♪
♪ My hand on heart ♪
♪ It's not a thing that
I've been dreaming of ♪
♪ And it goes without
my blessing ♪
♪ And leaves me in a rut ♪
♪ But it comes and goes ♪
♪ And fills me when I'm empty ♪
♪ Then it comes and shows ♪
♪ How I need you
when you're gone ♪
♪♪
♪ It quakes and moves ♪
♪ And breaks,
and shatters over me ♪
♪ In shapes of all these quiet,
sacred things I need ♪
♪♪
♪ My hand on heart ♪
♪ If there's a line or something
in these songs ♪
♪ That are worthy
of some mention ♪
♪ You're free to let me know ♪
♪ But it comes and goes ♪
♪ And holds me in my weakness ♪
♪ And it comes and goes ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ My hand on heart ♪
♪ It's not a thing
that I've been dreaming of ♪
♪ And it throws me
with my blessing ♪
♪ And it leaves me in a rut ♪
♪ But it comes and goes ♪
♪ And holds me
when I'm sleepless ♪
♪ And it comes and shows ♪
♪ How I need you
when you're gone ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]